well let's now speak to Eric Bruckner he
is a professor of European studies at
Stanford University he now joins me from
Dresden in Germany or as we've been
hearing there from our correspondents
about such different perspectives from
various countries including advice from
various ministers about just whether
people should travel over the summer so
how does the EU eventually come together
on this because they they have to at
some point you know I don't think it's a
big problem given that Germany is a
federal state and the European Union is
not we have a similar situation in
Germany in which the different governors
come to different conclusions based on
different problems based on different
density of population and no one makes
it a big deal that Germany is not acting
in one coherent way but we see different
ways of openings or later in different
parts of the country and the same is
true for the European Union and it's
different member states if Spain was hit
so hard and they think that it's way too
early to open the borders it makes
perfect sense for Spain well if a small
country like Luxembourg is complaining
that they feel cut off if Germany
doesn't open the borders and their
situation is much better in terms of
numbers than in Spain then Germany
should respond and the Minister of the
Interior gave in and will open sooner so
we have cross-border relationships with
Luxembourg much sooner than with other
countries sure Rick I see that part of
the plan is for countries with similar
overall risk profiles to open to each
other's tourists right so how will that
be determined especially with the
situation moving really very quickly and
then small outbreaks potentially
possible anywhere well I don't think
that an army of tourists is sitting on
their suitcases and can't wait to go to
places that we recently saw just from
what the situation in hospitals is I
think people will be very careful and
cross-border transactions will be
basically on professional traveling and
not so much that people can't wait to go
to vacation restore or to
beaches in Italy and in Spain but what
the European Union is responsible for is
to provide a framework of the mobility
of goods services capital and labour and
that includes services like tourism that
people get an understanding of what is
the channel of framework how we respond
to this depends very much on the
different discourses in each and every
member state and that makes perfect
sense given that we don't know where we
are at this point of the pandemic you're
talking about some really bilateral
agreements here and I know that the EU
wasn't initially keen on the idea of
these potential tourism corridors to
begin with what's changed their mind
here well we have a very sophisticated
and also dynamic relationship when it
comes to who's responsible for what
which competences do we shift from a
national to a supranational level and in
which area does the European Commission
have a say this is sometimes confusing
because in absence of leadership by the
European Commission one complains that
Europe is not doing enough or not doing
quickly enough well the same is true in
the member states of the European Union
like Germany in which angle America
could give some sort of a general
direction but now in the face of opening
the governor's play a much more
prominent role and the same is true for
the European Union with still a much
more decentralized share of competences
that we will continue to discuss when it
comes to solidarity who's helping with
how much and over what period of time
and all the related questions that we
have to discuss once after the pandemic
the economic crisis will hit harder or
approach no there professor of European
studies at Stanford University always
good to get your insights out on out as
era